Je suis très très heureux, d'être parmi --
les lumières me font mal aux yeux et
se reflètent sur mes lunettes.
Je suis très heureux et très honoré d'être parmi
des personnes très, très innovantes et intelligentes.
J'ai écouté les trois présentateurs précédents,
et devinez quoi ?
Toutes les choses que j'avais prévues de dire, ils les ont dites ici,
et il semble que je n'ai plus rien à dire.
(Rires)
Mais il y a une expression dans ma culture
qui dit que, si un bourgeon quitte un arbre sans rien dire,
ce bourgeon est un jeune bourgeon.
Donc je vais -- puisque je ne suis pas jeune, mais très vieux --
je vais dire quelque chose.
Nous organisons cette conférence, à un moment très opportun
parce qu'une autre conférence se déroule en ce moment à Berlin.
C'est le sommet du G8.
Le sommet du G8 suggère que la solution aux problèmes de l'Afrique
serait une aide massive de l'aide humanitaire,
quelque chose similaire au plan Marshall.
Malheureusement, personnellement, je ne crois pas au plan Marshall.
Un, parce que les bénéfices du plan Marshall ont été surestimés.
Ses principaux bénéficiaires ont été l'Allemagne et la France,
et c'était seulement 2,5 % de leur PIB.
Un pays africain moyen reçoit une aide de l'étranger
de l'ordre de 13 à 15 % de son PIB,
et ceci est un transfert de ressources financières sans précédent
des pays riches vers les pays pauvres.
Mais je veux dire qu'il y a deux choses qu'il nous faut relier.
La manière dont les médias occidentaux traitent de l'Afrique, et les conséquences que cela engendre.
En exposant la détresse, l'impuissance et le désespoir,
les médias disent la vérité sur l'Afrique, et rien que la vérité.
Cependant, les médias ne nous disent pas toute la vérité.
Car la détresse, la guerre civile, la faim et la famine,
même si elles font partie intégrante de la réalité africaine,
elles ne sont pas la seule réalité.
Et deuxièmement, elles sont la plus petite réalité.
L'Afrique comprend 53 nations.
Nous avons des guerres civiles dans six pays seulement,
ce qui veut dire que les médias traitent seulement de six pays.
L'Afrique a des opportunités immenses qui ne traversent jamais
le tissu de détresse et désespoir
que les médias occidentaux présentent généralement à leur audience.
Mais l'effet de cette présentation est que cela fait appel à la sympathie.
Cela fait appel à la pitié, cela fait appel à quelque chose qui se nomme charité.
Et, en conséquence, la vue occidentale
du dilemme économique africain est mal cadrée.
Le mauvais cadrage est le résultat de l’idée
que l'Afrique est un endroit de détresse.
Que devrions-nous faire pour ça ? Nous devrions donner à manger à ceux qui ont faim.
Nous devrions distribuer des médicaments à ceux qui sont malades.
Nous devrions envoyer des troupes de maintien de la paix
pour aider ceux qui endurent la guerre civile
Et faisant cela, l'Afrique a été dénuée d'initiative propre.
Je veux dire qu'il est important de reconnaitre
que l'Afrique a des faiblesses fondamentales.
Mais également, elle a des opportunités et beaucoup de potentiel.
Nous avons besoin de recadrer le défit auquel l'Afrique fait face
d'un défi de détresse,
détresse qui s'appelle réduction de la pauvreté,
à un défi d'espoir.
Nous le cadrons comme un défi d'espoir, qui est la création de richesses.
Le défi qui se présente à tous ceux qui sont intéressés par l'Afrique
n'est pas un défit de réduction de la pauvreté.
Ce devrait être un défit de création de richesse.
Une fois que l'on change ces deux choses --
si vous dites que les africains sont pauvres et qu'ils ont besoin qu'on réduise leur pauvreté
vous avez le cartel international des bonnes intentions
qui débarque sur le continent, avec quoi ?
Des médicaments pour les pauvres, de la nourriture pour ceux qui ont faim,
des troupes de maintien de la paix pour ceux endurent la guerre civile.
Et en faisant cela, aucune de ces choses n'est vraiment productive
parce que vous traitez les symptômes, pas les causes
des problèmes fondamentaux de l'Afrique.
Envoyer quelqu'un à l'école et lui donner des médicaments,
mesdames et messieurs, ne crée pas de la richesse pour eux.
La richesse est fonction du revenu, et le revenu vient si vous trouvez
une opportunité commerciale profitable ou un travail bien payé.
Maintenant, une fois qu'on commence à parler de la création de richesse en Afrique,
notre deuxième défi sera,
qui sont les agents créateurs de richesse dans n'importe quelle société ?
Ce sont les entrepreneurs. [Incompréhensible] nous dit qu'ils sont toujours
environ 4 % dans une population, mais 16 % les imitent ensuite.
Mais leur entreprenariat porte ses fruits.
Alors où devrions nous mettre cet argent ?
Nous devrions mettre de l'argent là où il peut se développer de manière productive.
Encourager l'investissement privé en Afrique, à la fois domestique et étranger.
Soutenir les institutions de recherche,
parce que la connaissance est une partie importante de la création de richesse.
Mais que fait la communauté internationale pour l’aide humanitaire en Afrique aujourd'hui ?
Ils transfèrent de grosses sommes d'argent pour les soins de base,
pour l'éducation de base, pour la lutte contre la faim.
Le continent entier a été transformé en
un endroit de détresse, en attente de charité.
Mesdames et messieurs, est-ce que l'un d'entre vous peut me parler
d'un voisin, d'un ami, d'un membre de votre famille,
qui est devenu riche en faisant appel à la charité ?
En tenant la sébile et recevant l'aumône ?
Est-ce que l'un d'entre vous dans le public connaît cette personne ?
Est-ce que l'un d'entre vous connait un pays qui s'est développé grâce à
la générosité et la gentillesse d'un autre?
Hé bien, comme je ne vois pas de main se lever,
il semble que ce que je déclare est vrai.
Bono : Oui!
Andrew Mwenda : Je vois que Bono dit qu'il connaît le pays.
De quel pays s'agit-il?
Bono: C'est un nom irlandais.
(Rires)
Bono: [incompréhensible]
Merci beaucoup. Mais laissez-moi vous dire ceci.
Des acteurs externes peuvent seulement vous présenter une opportunité.
La capacité d'utiliser cette opportunité et de la tourner en un avantage
dépend de votre capacité interne.
L'Afrique a reçu de nombreuses opportunités,
nombre d'entre elles ne nous ont pas beaucoup profité.
Pourquoi ? Parce que nous manquons de structures institutionnelles
et de structures politiques qui peuvent faire en sorte qu'il soit possible pour nous
de profiter de nos relations extérieures. Je vais vous donner un exemple.
Selon les termes de l'accord de Cotonou,
qu'on appelait autrefois Convention de Lomé,
l'Europe a donné l'opportunité à des pays d'Afrique
d'exporter des biens, hors taxes, sur le marché de l'Union Européenne.
Mon propre pays, l'Ouganda, a un quota pour exporter 50 000 tonnes
de sucre sur le marché de l'Union Européenne.
Nous n'avons pas encore exporté un seul kilogramme.
Nous importons 50 000 tonnes de sucre du Brésil et de Cuba.
Deuxièmement, selon les termes du protocole d'accord sur le bœuf,
Les pays africains qui produisent du bœuf
ont des quotas pour exporter du bœuf, hors taxes, vers les marchés de l'Union Européenne.
Aucun de ces pays, y compris le plus prospère d'entre eux, le Botswana,
n'a jamais atteint son quota.
Alors je veux soutenir aujourd'hui que la cause fondamentale
de l'incapacité de l'Afrique à entrainer le reste du monde
dans une relation plus productive
est la pauvreté des structures institutionnelles et politiques.
Et toutes les formes d'intervention ont besoin de support,
l'évolution des types d'institutions qui crée de la richesse,
les types d'institutions qui augmentent la productivité.
Comment commencer cela, et pourquoi l'aide humanitaire est un mauvais moyen d’y parvenir ?
L'aide humanitaire est un mauvais moyen, et vous savez pourquoi ?
Parce que tous les gouvernements à travers le monde ont besoin d'argent pour survivre.
L'argent est nécessaire pour des choses simples comme maintenir l’ordre public.
Vous devez payer l'armée, et la police pour maintenir l’ordre public.
Et, parce que nombre de nos gouvernements sont plutôt dictatoriaux,
ils ont en fait besoin d'une armée pour tabasser l'opposition.
La seconde chose dont vous avez besoin, c'est payer les parasites politiques.
Pourquoi est-ce que les gens devraient soutenir leur gouvernement ?
Hé bien, parce qu'il leur donne des emplois rémunérés.
Ou, dans de nombreux pays africains, des opportunités non officielles
de profiter de la corruption.
Le fait est qu'aucun gouvernement dans le monde,
à l'exception d'un petit nombre, comme celui d'Idi Amin Dada,
ne peut dépendre entièrement de la force comme instrument de règne.
De nombreux pays dans le [incompréhensible], ils ont besoin de légitimité.
Pour obtenir une légitimité, les gouvernements ont souvent besoin de fournir des choses comme l'éducation de base,
les soins de base, des routes, construire des hôpitaux et des cliniques.
Si la survie fiscale du gouvernement
dépend du fait qu'il doive collecter de l'argent de son propre peuple,
alors un tel gouvernement est motivé pour son propre intérêt
à gouverner d'une manière plus éclairée.
Il va s'entretenir avec ceux qui créent la richesse.
Leur parler des politiques et institutions
qui sont nécessaires pour étendre l'envergure des entreprises
pour collecter plus de taxes de leur part.
Le problème avec le continent africain
et le problème avec l'aide humanitaire
c'est que qu'elle a déformé les formes d'incitations
qui se présentent aux gouvernements en Afrique.
La marge productive dans la recherche de revenu de notre gouvernement
ne repose pas dans l'économie intérieure,
elle repose sur les donateurs internationaux.
Plutôt que de rencontrer des entrepreneurs ougandais --
(Applaudissements)
Plutôt que de rencontrer des entrepreneurs ougandais,
des hommes d'affaires ghanéens, des chefs d'entreprise sud-africains,
nos gouvernements trouvent plus productif
de parler au FMI et à la Banque Mondiale.
Je peux vous dire, même avec 10 doctorats,
vous ne battrez jamais Bill Gates pour ce qui est de comprendre l'industrie informatique.
Pourquoi ? Parce que la connaissance requise pour comprendre
les incitations nécessaires pour faire croitre une entreprise
requiert l’écoute des gens, des acteurs du secteur privé dans ce domaine.
En conséquence, la communauté internationale a donné
aux gouvernements d'Afrique une opportunité d’éviter
des ententes productives avec vos propres citoyens,
et de ce fait a permis de commencer des négociations interminables avec le FMI
et la Banque mondiale, et alors c'est le FMI et la Banque mondiale
qui leur disent de quoi leurs citoyens ont besoin.
De cette manière, le peuple africain a été écarté
des prises de décisions politiques, des orientations politiques, et du
processus de mise en oeuvre des politiques de nos pays.
Nous avons des moyens limités, car " Qui paie les violons choisit la musique. "
Le FMI, la Banque mondiale et le cartel mondial des bonnes intentions
se sont emparés de nos droits de citoyens,
et de ce fait, ce que font nos gouvernements, puisqu'ils dépendent de leur aide,
c'est écouter leurs créanciers internationaux plutôt que leurs propres citoyens.
Mais je veux aussi mettre en garde,
car il n'est pas vrai de dire que l'aide humanitaire est toujours destructrice.
Certaines aides ont pu permettre de construire un hôpital, nourrir un village affamé.
Elles ont pu construire une route, et cette route
a pu avoir un rôle positif important.
L'erreur de l'aide humanitaire de masse
est de choisir des succès isolés,
de les généraliser, et verser des milliards et des milliards de dollars,
et de reproduire les mêmes choses à travers le monde,
en ignorant les circonstances uniques et spécifiques d'un village particulier,
les compétences, les pratiques, les normes et les habitudes
qui ont permis à des petits projets d’aide de réussir --
comme dans le village nommé Sauri au Kenya où Jeffrey Sachs travaille --
et de ce fait généralisent cette expérience
comme l'expérience de tous.
L'aide humanitaire augmente les ressources disponibles aux gouvernements,
ce qui rend un emploi au gouvernement la chose la plus rentable
pour une personne africaine qui cherche à faire carrière.
En augmentant l'attrait politique de l'Etat,
surtout dans les sociétés aux groupes ethniques fragmentés,
l'aide tend à accentuer les tensions ethniques,
car chaque groupe ethnique commence maintenant à lutter pour faire partie de l'Etat,
pour avoir une part du gâteau de l'aide internationale.
Mesdames et messieurs, en Afrique, les plus entrepreneurs
ne trouvent pas d'opportunités de faire du commerce et travailler dans le secteur privé
parce que les politiques institutionnelles et l'environnement sont hostiles aux entreprises.
Les gouvernements ne changent pas cela. Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'ils n'ont pas besoin de parler à leurs propres citoyens.
Ils parlent aux donateurs internationaux.
Et les entrepreneurs africains finissent par travailler pour le gouvernement,
et cela augmente les tensions politiques dans nos pays
précisément parce que nous dépendons de l'aide internationale.
Je veux aussi dire qu'il est important pour nous de
noter que sur les 50 dernières années, l'Afrique a reçu une aide croissante
de la part de la communauté internationale
sous la forme d'assistance technique, d'aide financière,
et toutes les autres formes d'aides possibles.
Entre 1960 et 2003, notre continent a reçu 600 milliards de dollars d'aide,
et on nous dit encore qu'il y a beaucoup de pauvreté en Afrique.
Où est passé toute cette aide ?
Je veux utiliser comme exemple mon propre pays, l'Ouganda
et le type de motivations que l'aide internationale y a amené.
Le budget 2006-2007 prévoyait un revenu de 2 500 milliards de shillings.
L'aide internationale attendue : 1 900 milliards.
Les dépenses récurrentes de l'Ouganda -- par récurrentes qu'est-ce que je veux dire ?
Au jour le jour -- 2600 milliards.
Pourquoi le gouvernement ougandais dépense-t-il 110%
de ses propres revenus ?
C'est parce qu'il y a quelqu'un qui s'appelle l’aide internationale qui y contribue.
Mais cela montre que le gouvernement ougandais
ne se consacre pas à dépenser ses propres revenus
pour les investir de manière productive,
au lieu de cela, il alloue ce revenu
aux dépenses publiques.
L'administration publique, qui est pour une grande part du favoritisme en échange de support politique, prend 690 milliards.
L'armée, 380 milliards.
L'agriculture, qui emploie 18% de nos citoyens frappés par la pauvreté,
prend seulement 18 milliards.
Le commerce et industrie prennent 43 milliards.
Et laissez-moi vous montrer ce que constituent les dépenses publiques --
ou plutôt, les dépenses d'administration publique.
Voilà. 70 chefs de cabinets, 114 conseillers présidentiels --
qui en fait, ne voient jamais le président, à part à la télévision.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Et quand ils le voient physiquement, c'est pour une réception publique comme ici,
et même là, c'est lui qui les conseille.
(Rires)
Nous avons 81 gouvernements locaux ;
chaque gouvernement local est organisé comme le gouvernement central --
une bureaucratie, un cabinet, un parlement,
et tellement d'emplois pour les parasites politiques.
Il y en avait 56, et quand notre président a voulu
amender la constitution et supprimer les limites de renouvellement de mandats,
il a dû créer 25 nouveaux districts, et maintenant il y en a 81.
333 membres du parlement.
Il faut le stade de Wembley pour faire siéger notre parlement.
134 commissions
et des organismes du gouvernement semi-autonomes,
qui ont tous des directeurs avec des voitures et -- et la dernière chose,
ceci s'adresse à M. Bono. Il pourrait nous aider sur ce sujet dans son travail.
Une étude récente du gouvernement ougandais montre
qu'il y a 3 000 véhicules 4 roues motrices
aux quartiers généraux du Ministère de la Santé.
L'Ouganda a 961 cantons, chacun d'un a un dispensaire,
mais aucun d'eux n'a d'ambulance.
Les quatre-quatre aux quartiers généraux
conduisent les ministres, les secrétaires permanents, les bureaucrates
et les bureaucrates de l'aide internationale qui travaillent sur leurs projets
pendant que les pauvres meurent sans ambulance ou médicament.
Pour finir, je voudrais dire qu'avant de venir parler ici,
on m'a dit que le principe de TEDGlobal
est qu'un bon discours devrait être comme une mini-jupe --
assez courte pour éveiller l'intérêt,
mais assez long pour couvrir le sujet.
J'espère y être arrivé.
(Rires)
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)